Marcel starts off this our Tulsa
Oklahoma caller hey Marcel how are you
doing good how about yourself better
than I deserve sir how can I help
I'm always I'm 25 years old I have two
boys four into it I'm trying to
establish a a set goal and on plan how
to get out of debt far as my student
loans and have a lot of I'm a single
parent so I have a lot of bills just as
doing so I'm trying to figure out how to
how to go about doing that taking credit
okay
and so what do you do for a living work
for the gas company and what do you make
what's your household in oh right now
I'll make thirteen fifty you know mm-hmm
forty hours a week
yes sir yes sir and I get paid every
week so that's good that's good
and you got family in the area yes okay
where's the kids mom uh she recently
just got back in town she was she was
moved away in Atlanta so so you have the
custody of the boys right yes okay all
right and does she pay any child support
uh no okay okay and how much debt do you
have sir uh with my student loans and
medical bills of six seventeen thousand
maybe seventeen eighteen okay cool
and and a how much is your rent
oh right now it's five eighty five
that's good news that's good news okay
well you are you got a lot of stuff on
your plate man I mean you already knew
that you're trying to raise kids and and
you're working hard you're a good man
and you're trying to but making thirteen
fifty an hour feeding two kids with $500
rent that's about all that's happening
there there's no there's no wiggle room
in that budget you already knew that
didn't you yeah yeah so I'm just telling
you I think it's impressive if you just
feed your kids keep the lights on keep
the rent paid at the 13:50 rate tomorrow
and let's worry about
student loans a little bit later now
okay having said that we got to have
some hope for this situation the good
news about life Marcel is is that it's
never a snapshot it's a filmstrip and
what that means is it's ever-changing
you're not stuck where you are right now
next year is going to be different it's
either going to be better or worse but
it'll be different
yes true okay and so we're going to
start working towards making it better
because the best way for you to build a
quality life for you your boys and get
rid of this debt is we got to get your
income up okay
long-term right yes you're a good man
you're working hard I'm glad you got a
job but I want you to make twice that to
three years from now okay and I think
you're probably worth it and so you
don't know where you can get some
traction in your life financially you're
living right on the bubble and I don't
want this for you ten years from now and
it will be exactly what you're doing
you'll be doing exactly the same thing
you're doing right now ten years from
now
unless you plan a way out so we got to
have a new gameplan and to start with we
got to start thinking about what do you
want to be doing with your life if you
could do anything you wanted to do what
would you do that paid sixty or a
hundred and sixty thousand a year and
you don't have to answer me right now
but I want you to start thinking that
way and then what if one of the then
once you identify say I could be that
thing I know I've always wanted to do
that I really believe I could do that
but I got to have some training I got to
have an education I got to have a mentor
program an apprentice program whatever
it is to get there and that's going to
take me two years and go into this class
or taking this certification or doing
this or that right right and so we got a
plaint we got to figure out where we're
going and then make a plan to get there
that's your long term answer to your
financial equation too plus it's just
going to give you a better life all
right and then the short term is the
dreaded part-time job which is tough as
a single dad but if you can get some
family support and do you know even if
you just did a few little things and
made a thousand bucks a month
dude that changes your whole life right
now
I mean if I could add a thousand dollars
a month to your income right now I'd be
like woohoo because it changes these
ratios way doesn't it yes it does and
that could be cutting grass on the
weekends okay that could be um you know
uh I don't know walking somebody's dog I
don't know I don't know whatever you got
talent that you know how to do that you
can go do you you may be a computer
engineer I don't know what you do but
figure out something that you can do and
maybe it's a small business idea that
you just do for yourself because let me
give you an example and I'm not saying
you do this but I'm amazed at how much
money people make per hour just doing
little odd job things like like like
being a maid going into a lady's house
cleaning her house you make $25 an hour
doing that now and maybe there's
something the equivalent that you would
do this like that right I'm just saying
you're you go be a maid that's not my
point but but but I'm saying if you cut
grass for yourself for two people
you could have intent five dollars an
hour and do that do that on Saturday
mornings before the kids get up your
mama comes over and sits there while
they're still asleep or something I
don't know but let's start to think that
way with a short term to get the income
up and start to have some traction and
get a little distance between you
because you're so on the bubble that any
little thing right now is a freaking
crisis yes yes ok now am i saying
anything in all of this that's wrong ok
am i I'm asking you know oh no no no no
does this all make sense to you yes sir
now let me ask you this how how much
reading do you do oh not much not much
okay that's okay that's okay um here's
what I want you to do I want you to
become a reader I want you to turn the
television off the average millionaire
reads a nonfiction book a month I got a
friend of mine reading to a month
because he wants to be a two millionaire
okay so I'm gonna send you some books
and is I'm putting you in college right
now man on how to get your life
organized how to get your act together
where you go win and double your income
and it's not going to be easy if it was
easy everybody would do it right right
yes sir right but you got you got to
know that the average millionaire can't
tell you who got thrown off the island
they're there reading and doing other
stuff at night you know well and so turn
off your television when the kids go to
bed read 30 minutes a night and even if
you're a slow reader it doesn't that
you're not getting a grade on this only
grade on this is improving your life so
take your time if you don't understand
something read it three times and if you
don't understand that then email
somebody over at the office one of us
will explain it to you yes sir and so
we're going to school here because this
is how you make your life better is you
have knowledge tomorrow that you didn't
have today and you apply it is that fair
yes sir are you in a good church get
real good get some good men around you
and look for some men that are doing
well in the business community that
would walk with you in this journey
you're going on that'll put their arm
around you and say hey Marcel I'm gonna
walk with you I'm gonna love you and I'm
going to show you how to win get some
guys that are ahead of you on this
journey and they will show you how to
take the journey you hold on I'm gonna
send you a whole case of different books
you're going to be reading for the next
two years on everything I'll send you
hold on
you